hey guys it's a Eric here joined with
Mary hey we're checking out transformers
devastation it just came out today on
all consoles as well as PC fifty dollars
that's fighting them games and let stop
in and check it out right now we're just
kind of figuring out all the moves it's
giving us several different fighting
moves it's awesome because the different
characters each have different moves and
they have different ranged weapons so
you do get like a nice mix based on who
you pick and you can easily switch
between karma and it's got that sweet
sound that you're used to watch the
transformers good nostalgic feeling I
love car smash the whole visuals are
nostalgic like this is exactly what you
want from this kind of game like it's
really nice yeah these look like cartoon
feel to it which is just really
enjoyable to to look at it's fun it's
fun to drive to which I was worried
about but it's some hot doughnuts you're
fast but you're not it's not impossible
to see what's going on really guy feel
like I can see and I can play even
though it's really fast just nice and
responsive mm-hmm so you're a little bit
in a little bit into the game now it's
like right give or take about after the
tutorial stuff where they tell you how
to do stuff there's a nice little combo
there yeah there's a vehicle attack as
long as you perform your regular attacks
kind of in secession like there's a
heavy attack so i'm here to show you
this is my light attack and then i have
a heavy attack which is why and if i use
that correctly then they give me a
vehicle back and then each person also
gets a really nice heavy attack let's
see if i can find someone oh tell me
first there's a dodge which i'm using
right now mm-hmm um if I am in car form
and i'm at a full speed then there's an
coming out of like your car attack yep
and then there's also going into your
car attack as well so if I'm a person
and I double jump I'm getting hit but if
i double jump and then i hit my car i
should do like a ground pound
which is pretty nice as well and then
there's also that range weapon too right
yeah I have a ranged weapon here um
depends who you are but like this one's
a rocket launcher and then there's like
a flamethrower I think everyone goes to
right everyone that's kind of two
variants one's kind of Energon based
where's the other one oh you without
your special that's my special and
that's my Rocket just to show them all
cuz I was about to kill everyone so I
wanted to show you that one's here so
yeah you get a bunch of the different
moves but its basis of it what you were
saying earlier tez like it's you have a
light attack you of a heavy attack you
got like a Dodge I mean like it and then
you could turn into a car that's pretty
much you know like there's not it's not
too advanced yeah yeah I mean but it's
it's platinum games so you know like
it's got that nice you know I wouldn't I
don't want to go as far to say bayonet
or anything like that but you know it's
got those like feelings of bayonetta or
maybe Korra you know like just the
combat the fluidity of that nice combo
stuff and it feels really satisfying
when you get the combos off and it later
on when you get to fight someone again
you'll do hopefully you'll get that
Dodge where it slows down if you a
perfect dodge and you'll be able to
damage your opponent or your enemies a
lot more which is really fun yeah it's
it's got a nice feel to it and what we
were saying earlier yeah this is the
kind of game that if if you like this
kind of game you're gonna like this game
because this is a fun if you like these
types of games like this is right up
your alley if you like transformers then
definitely okay yeah that's sweet double
down it's also got Luke phat loot I'm
not I haven't figured out for my limited
play of like how to switch to those like
or if it just switches it for you but
you do pick up loot you did like a mini
puzzle there where you know you found a
beacon it's like Oh search and then like
it'll prompt you to you know do a little
puzzle thing and then they'll give you a
chest and like sometimes you know it'll
be in a different spot or something that
you'll just have to like look for but
yeah pretty pretty cool I guess yeah
just little i'm not sure see exactly
what everything is going to benefit yet
but there's other things involved like
I guess I wanted to go that way there's
there's other things you can you can
figure out still like there's health
upgrade or like not upgrades but there's
ways to like increase your health and
stuff that's helpful yep oh and also you
do every character we didn't mention to
has like a kind of special ability for
their character so I think like
sideswipes is I could do like lb or
whatever is like a dash or something
like a kind of closes in on the opponent
yes this is a car yeah I got dude drive
you there and so that that car coming
out a car attack where you're actually
like full speed you need to use that
right again yeah guys well especially in
this section because yeah it looks like
you you can't get through the wind area
without it and you can also use there's
two different attacks here when you're a
car at full speed so there's your light
attack of them use your heavy attack and
basically the only difference between
oses once it's a little bit longer time
and it's 0 and does a little bit more
damage but I mean at the end here
nothing is that is what's up with Klaus
man the claw game intense but it gives
you a nice little red warning hmm I
think there's some sound problems for
like when the Dodge and whatnot it is
pretty friendly you know I'm sure it's a
game that they want to kind of have a
wide range of an audience like for kids
as well that hopefully your kid I've eat
this game up awesome I know I'm hoping
that this kind of can get like you know
if I was if I was a parent and I had a
child I would definitely want him to
play this or her to play this because I
want them to feel the same happy as I
had when I watched transformers when I
was a kid which is kind of like why I
was so excited about this game when I
saw it at e3 like oh man like that's
gonna be awesome no it is awesome like
it's really fun to play it's like you
said it's just like the ideal game it's
like pure hack and slash e fun it's not
too hard it's just fun to play it brings
back those beautiful
I can't wait like I haven't gotten to
the point where I can play as Grimlock
yet but I'm sure that's gonna be like so
fun we'll have to like I wanted to get a
little further in the tutorial it's
still pretty early on in this game it's
like what like half hour in yeah I think
you're not too you're like like I said
you're like a little bit passage like
kind of just right out of the tutorial
stuff so I think you might have to but
they're just tiny the norm there you go
like it's the right thing and you get
stats which I still don't know where you
actually track but you know it's
probably just one of those things that's
nice to see that you're leveling up here
all right we got Sun let's more story
can you hear adoptive us it's calling
out to those insecticons somehow
directing them
he's learning
yeah constructor cons
how do we need this time ah that's
pretty funny to drive away getaway
vehicle so yeah this is like a you know
just to give you some car play as well
as just the kind of like beat-'em-up
hacking / but uh yeah that the whole
voice acting stuff is like really on
point from the from the time I play it
and it's just again nostalgia and all
the fun feelings of you know being a kid
again kind of for me it's probably for
you as well definitely see he can turn
into a tank what was the point huh
getting on the car to begin with a
little loopy yeah all right hey he's got
to be Opie he's that he's the biggest
Megatron do the Decepticons he's got to
be slightly ok tonight some interesting
drive mechanics boom uppercut oh my gosh
will shifty dude just constantly getting
away but yeah it was always it was a
fear of mine when i saw this like you
know not only do you have to make a
really interesting fighting game but you
have to make a reasonable driving game
out of this as well you know you can't
just can't just make it a fun hack and
slash because this requires so much
driving but it's fun it's a fun driving
game yeah i'm gonna eat up right now
it's all good he's the big boss for a
reason and I mean like it's part of like
the lower right to as well like if
you're not a bot you know you're going
to turn into a car so like it's it's
cooled that you get to have some some
fun as a automobile as well
thank you goes to the right all right
I'm winging it here oh I should have
touched that we like a safe that's in
have you in any way got you surrounded
no you down Oh an arena we have
absolutely destroyed this city that's
what happened in the movies right it's
bound to happen like this they'll deal
with it after the fact apparently
there's no need for more movies which
boggles my mind but that's a thing why
not how I do not know but I think those
movies make a lot of money regardless
but like you would think like people
would stop watching them by now they're
just getting worse and worse no I don't
think it matters people enjoy the ride I
was so upset last time like nobody rides
Grimlock come on I don't even think I
don't just take my word for it you don't
want to watch it Oh see there's the
Dodge where you kind of slow down time
yeah give him the special I will Oh big
damage Wow you killed him first try that
took me a while well i only got a year
ank but yeah it's it's based on time and
damage so obviously there's some
learning to do but again like yeah it's
not it's not to punish a mess of the
battle he punished me Anna no man that
took me like a tries but uh I didn't I
always liked being stingy as my super
and like I think you got him in a good
spot where like corner immediate make
him eat rockets yeah because like that
uh the way that arena was set up that uh
the ring actually does damage to hitting
him back yes between the ring and my
rocket so that's interesting
call in place your first need to disable
three sub generators once does it need
the primary generator would be Autobots
transform rule out you got it off this
time to find those generators marry only
three of them all right and it's not
timed actually gotta get those logs
secret slang rounds this is considered a
generator I love the stores they left
for us one was sparking plug oh sweet
alright so see the stats so you can dark
star saber level 4 so we're upgrading oh
so this is this must be like the store
or kind of like you're you know you've
collected all your stuff and here is
kind of where you can look at the gear
that you found or picked up so that's
kind of cool go photon disruptor a basic
machine gun I feel like that's what
bumblebee is using yeah I think that's
what you're using right now in size
quake swords mmm you should
yeah Oh little knuckle sandwich I
haven't shown a lot of the ranged
weapons but they are pretty useful and
you end up using them a lot yeah I don't
know I haven't tried using them while
like kind of like in melee combat but it
seems like a thing that they kind of
want you to use when you're fighting
stuff above you because you can't reach
some of those higher up guys but you can
switch characters all right great
there's a sideswipe Oh Prime how come
he's dark Prime Nemesis Prime costume
they wanted to dominate him always such
a cutie pie it's got the red alert yeah
now he's normal yeah okay so it looks
like you can switch the costume switch
him out I like that what do you want
he's up to you you're you're driving
totally up to you do you want to play
you want to go leader of the Autobots I
do good choice good choice can never go
wrong with Prime so I think often miss
uh the cool thing about him is he has
like a his light attacks like a sword
and his heavies like an axe pretty cool
yeah so there is a dodge like you're
mentioning earlier but you have to be
you've to time it correctly can't use it
when you use it correctly it slows time
which is kind of RAD gives you like a
nice little slow down effects you can
see everything very kind of like
Bayonetta you just track through them
your attractively a big rig if I could
hurt that but I can't and things there
to impede your progress well yeah it's
very satisfying when you kind of get to
dodge off and like you get the timing
down I wouldn't say it's like
blood-borne um like he knows no feelings
reasonable here hey it still feels
pretty satisfying when you do it though
more bayonet ish but definitely more
than
aneta it's like a fun hack and slash e
adventure but it's colorful and fun and
it gives you the wonderful feeling if
you're wondering you know like will it
give me that awesome feeling like
playing or like watching transformers
with the credit really does it really
gives you like a fun feeling from like
your childhood and that's what's so fun
about it i think the art style helps so
much as well like just the direction
payment would I I didn't really play
those previous transformers games that
have been coming out over the last
couple years that were you know like
more realistic ish looking you know but
this one for whatever reason like for
the nostalgia alone oh just this is kind
of what it would have looked like back
when the cartoons are happening and I
get to play like I totally was like yep
I'm getting that day one you can also
change their equipped yep so you have an
ion blaster and grenade launchers you
know Optimus would you use a grenade
block that is so optimus but hey it's
gotta have a heavy weapon type you know
oh is that one of the fees
mine otto chair are they gonna make
Devastator or is it just a couple of
them do a scrapper and hook the scrap
they stand no chance without turning
into Oh big Friesian oh he's really fast
though sure is no I shouldn't be saying
you'd even prompts here yeah it gives
you that they're yours I will say there
is a slight art to it even though it
does prompt to you you can't just mash
it no I think if you I mean you can but
kind of would remind me of oh man
knowing that I it's got that like Batman
and it feel to it right now to you oh if
you spam it you will get hit that's
actually a good comparison I'm just kind
of curious though like as you're playing
this like you know it's been like
probably like you're 30 45 minutes in
maybe an hour probably not but you feel
like combats gonna get repetitive ah I
think the fact that you can play is
different Autobots really really helps
because when I feel like I've had enough
playing as Optimus and I will play as
something else and that is a huge help
but yes I I do but I mean you have to
like these types of games like let's be
reasonable here you know like yeah if
you if you're not really into like a
hacking hacking flash games like of
course they're gonna get repetitive like
so did devil may cry for that matter but
it was fun like I didn't care but that
is the reality right I'm just curious if
there's gonna be we saw that there's
nice there's a you know weapons that are
different I just kind of curious if they
gain movesets or anything like that or
they kind of stay the same the game
movesets you know again we're early here
I think that would be cool it's just
that right now it's like light or heavy
attack turn into a car yeah yeah
I wanted to try to grab pound them but
yeah hence will always plant it right ya
see that gives you a pretty long stun
try his a lb right I'm kind of curious
oh it's like wow it's pretty vicious
that's better than sideswipes if that
was the lb yeah it wasn't a super right
that was this is lb that was yeah his
left bumper which is like a special news
that's really good and what it seems to
you is basically just do a complete
circle around you it's really nice area
look move if you're like surrounded by
enemies which I was so all right that
the generator and one of them this looks
like searching something I have to
search yeah Hackett optimus
first sup generator shutdown 103 should
now be weakening the next to self
generators are now accessible shut them
down in any sequence
great news all right so you know that
was a look at a transformers devastation
out today yeah fifty dollars on yeah
it's not full priced release it's only
50 bucks 10 bones shoves 60 but it
doesn't have a competitive multiplayer
or anything like that it's just this
campaign yeah I think there's some
challenge mode stuff but yeah you guys
can check it out if you want to I think
it's a pretty fun game especially if
you're into platinum games especially
also if you're into transformers
nostalgia but um yeah thanks for
watching yeah thanks guys this fun
awesome getting destroyed back here
you